President Vladimir Putin's words
signaled a new phase of Russia's war in
Ukraine formalizing what he said was
pre-existing military rule in the
annexed regions of Donetsk luhansk
zapore and her son
I signed a decree on the introduction of
Martial law in these four entities of
the Russian Federation it will be
immediately sent to the Federation
Council for approval
Putin also established local Army
Headquarters and a special coordination
Council in the regions under the
leadership of Russia's prime minister
the decree comes among threats of a new
offensive by the Ukrainian armed forces
and an extensive Russian operation to
move tens of thousands of people from
Herson to the Southern Bank of the
Junipero River
they are told it's to protect them from
Ukrainian shelling
there is a continuing evacuation to give
the peaceful population a chance to
cross To the Left Bank of the kherson
region the entrance to the region is
closed for civilian for seven days
through all directions and all Crossings
under Russian law the decree means the
evacuations can now become compulsory
and the authorities can impose any
measures they see fit including
restricting public life or forcing
people to join the Army civilian
Industries and services can also be used
for military purposes
the new commander of the Russian
operation in Ukraine Sergey sorovicin
acknowledged the situation is difficult
for Russian forces and said what he
called painful measures might be
required the Russian army has suffered
major defeats in eastern and southern
Ukraine since early September it's not
clear what Undeclared measures the new
phase might include in terms of tactics
or types of weapons that Russia might
deploy to reverse those defeats Muhammad
al-jazeera Moscow